這幾天的時間
才3天的時間上漲2000多點
你有沒有覺得很誇張
不會誇張啊
可是我有三大問題
我今天要一次解析
第一個 今天的重點
輝達財報好到爆炸
但毛利率卻下滑
可是輝達盤後是上漲
怎麼會這樣子 如何解讀
到底是利多還是利空
還是我說的喜中藏悲 悲喜交加
還是第二個
第二個問題 來
台股開高走低
46000不守 為什麼
我一次講個夠
第三個 好不容易成交量回溫了
9000億了
是漲真的還是漲假的
今天哲哲一次講個夠
台股短短3天大漲快2200點
一眨眼又突破46000了
最後漲了142點
收漲在45975點
投資長早就預告
台股不會打第二隻腳
也不會跌破40000點
還說過要是漲到43000的時候
你會覺得可惜
47000的時候是可憐
50000點的時候是可悲
而投資長的股票真的很強
投資長的好戲登場
精材這檔股票
股價又快噴漲停啦
台股一飛沖天
最重要的原因就是輝達財報大爆發
你想知道AI
是到底如何影響台股的嗎
接下來就交給我們
經濟日報選股冠軍
單季188%的紀錄保持者
同時也是全台灣唯一百萬粉絲
最受歡迎的分析師
郭哲榮投資長 投資長好
Lily 各位投資朋友大家好
真的很誇張
你剛才說3天漲了快2200點 對
很多人覺得怎麼那麼誇張
你們又開始算我的財富了是不是
就是從月底
上個月底到現在
大概賺差不多1500萬
So what 我不在乎
我在乎的是我何時能捐救護車
老天要送給我 賺錢給我花
我就捐救護車
我說過至少50000點
有可能60000點
因為明年應該輕輕鬆鬆過60000點
我的想法是這樣子 我再講一次
4到5年內 甚至4年內
甚至我覺得快一點3年內10萬點
你不要以為我跟你開玩笑
台灣50到時候到60000點
我大概賺5000萬
1億賺5000萬
再捐第三台救護車
我捐的救護車就是要500萬起跳
不是一般的巴士或怎麼樣
當然我覺得願意捐
都是很好的事情
哲哲都比個讚
只是我要捐就捐貴一點 第三台
可是我捐救護車我很開心
我更開心的是
這一波大家跟我一起賺錢
有些人之前卡住
現在感覺 至少感覺要賺錢
量有出來了 你知道嗎 是
真的量有出來
所以投資朋友
我們看一下這個量
今天順便跟大家講那個
台灣股市的量出來
哲哲 為什麼
等一下喔
我買在這邊對不對 對
很多人說
為什麼今天台灣股市又上影線
莫名其妙
怎麼給我開高走低才漲142點
最後期指才漲75點
142點最後期指才漲75點
今天可能吃太多了
我平常錄影之前
都告訴自己不能吃炸
今天開心之下
稍微吃了一點點炸的東西
不然基本上我都不吃炸的
我以前很愛吃
現在不吃炸的
來 這個跟大家講
我們來看一下
所以剛才打嗝了
不尊重我的行業
我自己不尊重
扯遠了 開玩笑
哲哲是非常對自己嚴格的男人
來看一下
台股跟費半你不覺得好像沒有關係
一個往下 一個往上有沒有 對
很明顯嘛 很明顯
一個往下 一個往上有沒有看到
所以台灣股市跟費半已經有點
怎麼關聯性不高了
不對 台灣股市跟費半
相關係數非常高的
所以一個往上 一個往下
有人說我大舌頭 ㄣㄤ不分
沒有錯
不要說要去上國語正音班
我上過了
還第一名畢業的
因為同學都是外國人
真的嗎 真的啊
外國人才要去上國語正音班
一般人哪會去上
還有一些可能想要當主播的人 是
有些人都不喜歡當主播
有些人都想要去當直播了
那斯達克
可是直播也不好賺
每個人都是一樣
其實直播跟YouTuber都是一樣
都是第一名賺比較多啦
第二名 第三名還有得喝
第四名 第五名以後真的是很辛苦
跟藝人一樣
分析師其實也有一點點像
那斯達克往下有沒有看到
你看台灣股市往上
所以台灣股市已經算一枝獨秀
台灣股市
人家都還沒有創歷史新高
台灣股市準備創歷史新高
你不要開玩笑
所以接下來如果美國股市再大漲
我給你一個結論
接下來美國股市大漲
譬如說美國股市我漲個2%
漲那麼多喔
台灣股市有漲一半就偷笑了
有漲1%就偷笑了
記得我這件事
因為為什麼
因為我們要等人家迎頭趕上來
我們要等人家趕上來懂不懂
不可能那種
費半指數一直破底
假設啦 現在沒有
一直破底 台灣股市一直創新高
你要記得這個邏輯
所以不要緊張
Lily那個蛤很緊張
其實重點是
這個行情
台灣股市已經是領先者了
領頭羊了
不用緊張啦 好不好
所以今天漲多
拉回很正常啦
重點是什麼
重點是上櫃指數
這是大盤對不對
上櫃指數漲比較多有沒有看到
可是上櫃指數漲比較多
可是上櫃指數怎麼樣
離前高有一點距離 是不是
這樣看更明顯
上櫃指數跌很慘有沒有
前高在這邊有沒有看到 對
這邊也可以 好不好 來 放大
有看到嗎
前高在這邊
是不是距離有點遠
有一點遠 是不是 好
我們看一下上市的走勢
是不是差不多了
所以大盤已經離新高很近了
離48000
怎麼轉眼變48000了
哲哲 你怎麼賺1500萬很輕鬆
為什麼
哲哲也是從零開始的
我出社會的時候一毛錢都沒有
有當兵啦 考上輔導長
大概存了10幾萬
就這樣子 一毛錢都沒有
哲哲不是富二代 好不好
還有網路上謠傳我富二代
真好笑 你可以問我媽媽
我媽媽每天都說有哲哲真好
再講下去太臭屁了
我還算孝順我媽媽
真的可以去問他
問他也沒有用 沒有啦 好啦
媽媽我愛你
他每天都會看我的節目
不是富二代 從零開始
怎麼覺得哲哲賺錢很簡單
不是 你們都是從零開始
把握住每一次的轉折
每一次的轉折 這是我的名言
再一次跟你講
創新高你也不敢追
拉回30%你也不敢買
你乾脆退出股市算了
我是不是跟你講
40000點的時候告訴你
叫你All in就All in
叫你重壓就重壓
你不理我能怎麼辦
你不理財 財不理你
這就是人生
最傻的就是把他放在定存
記得這件事情
我沒有告訴你說一定要買什麼股票
我跟你講 我也可以不收會員
可是你要會投資
你不會投資
你就是被那些資本主義
你被資本家 被蠶食鯨吞
錢全部送給他
銀行為什麼都可以賺幾百億 幾千億
因為你把錢放在銀行
他把錢拿去靈活運用
就這麼簡單
你看定存
我昨天看到定存1.5還1.6
1.5不到
導播幫我查一下
去查一年期定存利率
我說這什麼爛東西 定存利率
現在通膨都不只3 4%了
實質通膨 我的感受啦
1.6啦 定存1.6啦
台灣50一年就2 30%
你看連趙建銘的兒子都知道
2300萬 爸爸 你幫我投資
2300萬早就應該翻倍了
網友幫他算
3年應該到8000萬了啦
隨便投資都可以賺錢 就是不投資
那就是我說的
來 再看一下 再刺激大家一下
可惜 可憐 可悲
助理不是說有給我
43000可惜有沒有
這個圖不行啦
助理 43000在這邊啦
不知道哪個助理
要訓練一下
43000在這邊有沒有
這邊43000可惜有沒有 是不是 是
43000可惜 可憐 是不是
現在要可憐了
50000可悲
43000應該擺在這邊 助理
可惜 可憐 可悲
你以為這邊是可割可棄
可以割捨的 可以丟棄的
沒有 我跟你講趕快買喔
現在很多記憶體股
還有航運股要噴了喔
不要說我沒說喔
我跟你講 不要說我沒說
等一下我跟你講輝達財報
我直接跟你講輝達財報結論
人家說明年營收要增加70%
天啊 毛利率不是下滑嗎
怎麼75%要下滑到71 72%
怎麼會有這樣的財報
很多人是先看毛利率 先行指標
通常毛利率下滑
營收增加沒有啥用
為什麼這一次會這樣子
我直接給你結論
我也不要看AI圖 我告訴你
因為營收增加70%
你下滑4%又怎麼樣
而且因為營收
毛利率下滑3% 4%又怎麼樣
大家都知道
其實他已經把大家
最恐慌的恐懼講出來了
因為記憶體太貴了
所以我毛利率下滑
可是因為記憶體太貴
我毛利率下滑
可是我的營收增長
完全可以抵消我的毛利率下滑
再講一次
我的營收增長70%
我毛利率下滑3%可不可以 可以
很好的一個交換
要不要交換 要
你營收增加70% 增加一倍
然後毛利率下滑3%要不要 要
要嘛 而且營收不只增加70%
他說要不是供給不足
要不是生不出來記憶體
這個我有沒有跟你講過
你知道為什麼要嗎
我就跟你講
大部分人看不到哲哲看到的未來
你知道嗎 是
我昨天有看到
我講一個東西
我很想給你看我的心血管指標
就是我大概 因為我滿敏感
我看到家族有人
都是大概50幾歲中風的時候
我覺得我膽固醇要降低
我那時候覺得膽固醇越低越好
我也很想給你看我的膽固醇
我在北投健康醫院做健康檢查
那個花滿貴的
我比較怕死 因為要服務你們
我大概從2021年開始
我的膽固醇從160給它降到30 20
低密度膽固醇
可是你知道現在有文獻出來了
現在美國的心臟內科協會好像就講
你要從年輕開始
就像我講的膽固醇這樣子
膽固醇是這樣
你到這個額度慢慢累積
你越快到這個額度
爆了就直接中風了
或心肌梗塞死掉
或腦中風這樣子
所以現在的
所以我之前跟你講
我現在在看文獻
現在開始
他說你的血管會堵塞
不是從40歲 50歲
而是從你很年輕的時候
低密度膽固醇
開始超過100的時候
你就開始累積 開始累積斑塊
開始堵塞 堵塞到最後剝落了
就會堵塞了 就Byebye了
我5年前去跟醫生講的時候
我說我想要膽固醇降低一點
那醫生覺得我莫名其妙很怕死
我發現現在已經變顯學了
再過5年就知道
我講的都是真的
我都預設未來 你懂不懂
我真的很變態
5年前的時候我就告訴我自己
低密度膽固醇可能要越低越好
所以現在越來越多
心臟內科的醫生都跟你講這些
我再去利用AI去查這些東西
但是我這個扯遠了
我只跟你講我看的未來
你要相信我
10萬點很快就快到了 你懂不懂
我不會跟你講肯定的時間
因為我是合格分析師 懂不懂
我不是那些網紅 是不是
你怎麼知道他到底有沒有偷偷買股票
一堆股票給你偷偷買
你跟我說他不會做這個事
我還真的很難相信
不是每個人像哲哲這樣
經得起利益的誘惑 真的
真的不是
有些人為了5萬塊 10萬塊
是會翻臉的 兄弟翻臉的
我跟你說真的
所以我要講的是說
我真的人在做天在看
我很喜歡當那種
我不喜歡只當分析師
我喜歡當預言家
5萬點噴出去你就知道 我跟你講
到時候哲哲號三號
慶祝台股10萬點
第三台救護車
因為我捐救護車可能要6萬點
等到我送出救護車的時候
可能已經10萬點了 是
不要以為不可能 我跟你講
記得我說的這些東西
所以你們膽固醇超過100的
低密度的趕快降一降 好不好
趕快降一降 我是為大家想的
真的 好不好
中風 好處中風心肌梗塞
可能就Byebye了
無痛 痛一下
難過的是你中風救好了
那就很麻煩了 你知道嗎
但是都不要就好了
哲哲大GG 你說台積電嗎
你這樣公然性騷擾我 來
買ETF跟買個股風險不一樣
借錢敢All in的人
借錢不要
借錢All in個股真的不一樣
好不好
哲哲是不是說
300元以下鴻海都可以買
不是再也見不到300元鴻海
要認真聽哲哲說話
對啊 你們是把那個以前
再也見不到600元以下台積電
這句話
跟300元的鴻海湊在一起
我沒有說再也見不到300元鴻海
可是鴻海300元以下可以買
好不好 OK嗎 來
膽固醇有基因型還有膽固醇針
對 這個我有打PCSK9
我再告訴你
心肌梗塞就聽不到
你慷慨激昂的發表了
我5年前就是這樣子 真的
跟大家講好不好
現在真的最新文獻都是
降膽固醇從年輕開始
記得喔 好不好
我就是人生有個使命
讓你們賺到錢
然後健康快樂
把睡眠搞好 把三高
血壓 糖尿病
糖尿病其實用
用現在那個減肥針就可以了
還可以減重
血壓 糖尿病 膽固醇
三個把它降好
然後睡好
不要給自己太大的壓力 多賺點錢
長命百歲 開開心心 常常出遊
你們會愛上我
這是我的使命 真的
久了就知道哲哲沒有一定要賺錢
哪有哲哲推薦參加會員的
每次要不要講都隨便大家
有時候還Lily提醒我 沒錯
最後一分鐘要不要參加會員
有這個專案 好不好
哲哲寶貝 點一個國巨
國巨 世界
國巨卡住了
禾伸堂都漲了
你要點一個國巨對不對
我們先點一首歌啦 好
來 你今天要清唱對不對 對
我們那個歌
對 那個歌我沒有歌詞
他們忘記給我了
今天這個輝達財報太瘋狂了
太瘋狂了是不是 是
對啊 謝謝 來
字卡群看一下 來 馬上
給你唱一首歌
來 等一下
這邊有一種悲傷
他不是悲傷 是開心對不對
是瘋狂
有一種瘋狂 來
所以我們來唱一下
來 Music 點一首歌
哪一種瘋狂
是投資長
3 2 1
有一種瘋狂
是投資長的飆股又一路上漲
精材要噴出
漲停就在眼前晃 真的太強
有一種飆漲
是輝達財報太強
AI又火力全開呀
台股衝高 飆股全部跟著漲
不錯 你把一首很悲傷的歌
還是有點悲傷 我不知道怎麼
也不錯啦 又悲傷又瘋狂啦
剛才清唱給我聽的時候
是有點瘋狂 現在沒有
可是好聽
音好像 Key都滿準的
投資長的飆股一路往上漲
精材要噴出
真的啦 精材要噴出了啦
精材我講一下
投資長的飆股真的很強啊
真的 等一下再秀一個簡訊
精材要噴出去
你看啊 你250不買
不是一樣嘛 週年慶不買
是不是 拉起來
最近好像那個晶華酒店
好像也是在週年慶還是怎麼樣
又週年慶了
不是又 大家都週年慶
你們那個什麼精品商店啊
那邊好像有香奈兒 愛馬仕嘛
投資朋友 頂多打5折啊
而且都給你點數
還要下次再消費
那5%下次要消費
你好不容易消費了20萬
賺那1萬塊
還要下次再消費 越買越貴 真的
股票不用啊
股票不用下次回饋你啊
直接打折啊
直接退現金給你
不要 8折也不要
7折也不要 9折也不要
我再想要再買7折
你想太多啦 知道嗎
國巨怎麼看
我就說了 國巨555
你看禾伸堂
禾伸堂是 來 我看一下
謝謝你 禾伸堂
有沒有 675
禾伸堂675
禾伸堂的股價比國巨高
沒有意義啦
國巨我跟你講
我跟你講禾伸堂明天再噴一根
我跟你講禾伸堂明天只要5%
你記得我的預告
禾伸堂如果明天再5% 是
國巨明天會接近漲停板 真的嗎
我覺得機率滿高
我跟你講 我是合格的分析師
我不會跟你說100%
但是我覺得機率滿高
就這樣
機率很高啦
我的盤感你要相信我 好不好
老大不發威
你當我是病貓你知不知道
我為什麼 其實我也可以買
其實我也可以買
那些最小型的被動元件
我就是要買國巨
我要讓你知道
我喊水會結凍
我要讓你知道 我跟你講
我就是大型股
你不用考慮我買那些奇怪的小型股
會不會故意出貨給你 不用
而且法院也已經證明我清白了 好不好
去年有人亂告 直接簽結
簽結就是要兩個檢察官
覺得根本就沒有
還動用證交所 還查所有的這個
我的會員的進出簡訊
我有沒有在偷買偷賣
完全沒有異常帳號
台灣全部的帳號裡面都沒有
經得起考驗
投資的誠信
你絕對可以嚴格要求我
好不好 投資的誠信
好不好 這個跟大家講
分析師要看我這個啦 來
所以我們來看
你去想想看你要怎樣的分析師啦
來 來看一下
禾伸堂噴出去 來
我告訴你
禾伸堂明天再漲
國巨你就知道了
所以我跟你講
600元以下的國巨 我跟你講
你趕快珍惜 好不好
我只能說珍惜
不要說下去500多
快買啦 真的啦 我沒騙你啦
你看今天還有什麼
那個 氣死了 華新科
心花怒放那個
華新科有沒有看到
華新科比國巨更厲害有沒有看到
華新科明天要噴出去我跟你講
華新科今天拉尾盤
漲真的啦
被動元件這一波就是因為散戶在亂啦
那些散戶走了
那些散戶就這樣
國巨明天漲 那散戶就開始
開始賣掉了
那個股東人數就減少了
他會一直有賣壓 慢慢拉起來
你久了就覺得
國巨怎麼那麼便宜
我就說你們很奇怪
1200的國巨跟500
跟476.5元的國巨
基本面沒有差別啊 各位
講話很像以前我喜歡的一個藝人
蔡頭
不知道你有沒有聽過 有
基本面沒有差別啊 各位
但是我們是靠腦袋過日子
不是說人家沒有 我們是啦
且看哲哲且珍惜好不好
哲哲燃燒生命
哲哲說三高不是最好
我覺得我的膽固醇會降低啦 是
糖尿病也OK啦
體重有在維持啦
我就是那個高血壓我比較怕
每天錄完以後
可能血管要爆炸 真的
且看且珍惜
不過我還滿喜歡跟你們聊天的
1220元啦
跟456.5元有差別嗎
沒有 基本面沒差
你們不要在那邊亂
買不到了我跟你講 來
哲哲大肌肉 金居怎麼回事
原來大家這麼愛哲哲
不是沒有原因的 笑死
好激動喔 是不是 來
哲哲可以看一下聯電嗎
聯電不是要擴產嗎
哲哲寶貝 肌肉猛男
手上如果有黃金的話
建議賣掉轉台股嗎 當然啦
我跟你講 黃金叫做
送你四個字
不事生產
而且黃金現在是不是怎樣
我問你一件事
當然我不是說
以前大家也覺得鑽石很保值啊 是
現在鑽石有保值嗎 沒有
你怎麼知道
你知道為什麼鑽石沒有保值
就是常常都會聽到大家說
你知道什麼原因嗎 不太知道
現在人工鑽石看不出來差別
自己培育的
去實驗室也分不出來差別
真的嗎 對啊
中國很恐怖喔 莫斯科很恐怖喔
看不出來差別
看不出來差別我們就買假鑽就好啦
5克拉才多少錢
以前5克拉應該要差不多
5 600萬吧 可能更高
現在5克拉 可能更高喔
因為每差1克拉30萬
5克拉應該不止了對不對
你現在5克拉應該
1 20萬就可以買到吧 對啊
那買真鑽幹嘛
那買黃金幹嘛
一樣啊 不事生產好不好
這東西要是哪個技術開發出來了
沒有意義啦
你這個不一樣嘛 你知道嗎
我很想跟你講
我捐救護車的時候
我那時候捐第二台救護車的時候
我想說一句話
我說不好意思
我只是剽竊
台灣台積電各個工程師
還有政府努力的成果
我是這樣講 我是認真講
我只是剛好 什麼叫剽竊
因為你們很努力
我只是搭上這一台順風車而已
真的啊 什麼意思
我覺得我沒有做非常多的事情
就是我看到低點就買啦
你們很努力幫我賺錢啦
就這樣子而已啊
懂嗎 你在投資ETF
投資股票的時候
是一群人在幫你賺錢耶 是
黃金要幹嘛
用膝蓋想也知道啊
抗通膨
我再講一件事情
你剛才講說定存1.7%
台灣50這5年的報酬
每年是23%耶
比巴菲特厲害
巴菲特也才20%而已 是
這樣懂我的意思嗎 好不好
賣掉美債血壓就降了
你不要再說
再說我血壓爆掉 我跟你講
1.74億美債放在那邊
誠信兩個字啦
投資誠信你不用來考慮
不用來質疑我啦 知不知道
少賺2億啦 沒有關係啦
只是那個
我那個2億現在變成什麼
真的少賺2億
那2億也變成失憶啦
跟僅剩回憶啦
好啦 來
我黃金買4500 買1月的高價
那時候2萬的高點獲利
獲利120幾萬
黃金不是每天那麼好賺啦 來
鑽石恆久遠
泰銘小老弟
你叫人家小老弟
你黃金大賺120幾萬
我底下要不要留言 留個100多
這個邏輯很奇怪
可是我黃金大賺120幾萬
這個邏輯不覺得很奇怪
有點前後文不對
前後不對啊 報酬率多少
然後第二個
你的總資產多少 我怎麼知道
底下可以一堆留言
我會員來留言
看一堆人好不好
或者我的粉絲
你告訴他們這一波你賺幾千萬
不要來亂
我們這邊是有學識的
第二個 我跟網紅不一樣
網紅你可以討厭他
你抵制我 我也沒差
第一個 我不缺錢
第二個 我靠股票可以過日子
第三個 準不準才重要
你不喜歡我 別人還是會看我的節目
我沒差啊
我不是靠你抖內賺錢的 各位
懂不懂 OK嗎
這個跟大家講
重點是準不準啦
我不準 再帥都沒有用 OK
所以我們這邊要有學識
沒有邏輯的話
不要在這邊亂丟 好不好
沒關係 你要丟沒關係
可是你不要嗆我
這樣我會嗆回去
好啦 開玩笑
不是開玩笑 是半認真
因為有時候我講說助理封鎖
網路上說哲哲怎麼可以封鎖人
如果有人天天罵你
你說這個人
那我就天天罵你 你不要封鎖我
對不對 看你受不受得了 是不是
然後我要封鎖網友還不行
至少我是個男子漢
我說封鎖就封鎖對不對
好啦 扯遠了
哲哲 航運完了嗎
早就完了
我們看一下航運股好不好
就說航運股玩假的 你就不理我
他跟AI有關係嗎
我只問你跟AI有關係嗎
有沒有 沒有啦
你看 跟AI有關係嗎
今天彈一根
我跟你講啦
你說會不會創新高
就算他漲上去又怎麼樣
就像塑化股一樣
擦邊球都沒有用 懂不懂
給你看一下重播 來
航運股萬海有沒有看到 是不是
最高點的時候
2615萬海
航運股強講萬海
等到航運股真的要叫你買的時候
結果給你開高走低 是不是
航運股強講陽明
今天有點開高走低
航運股強才講他
我跟你講現在航運股跌了
長榮今天跌了
受不了才叫你買
我說這叫老投顧
老投顧有沒有 漲上去才講
你看這幾天多少人講航運股
別家投顧的
摩爾投顧的分析師
大家都滿認真的
但是我不會特別針對誰
那都是老投顧表演
你如果那種行情不好
你還相信每天講漲停板的
各位你被騙剛好
第二個 臉書
現在我的都被那些詐騙集團給殲滅了
我臉書的帳號
你絕對不要加 好不好
臉書提供的LINE絕對不要加
這樣懂不懂 OK嗎
我臉書現在沒有正式的官方帳號
不要加
臉書有廣告的都是詐騙
我已經有講了
我不能每天講這個東西
IG跟Threads也是一樣
用我的帳號
看起來是我的帳號
結果截圖叫你加另外一個LINE
也是假的
只能加這個LINE 懂不懂
IG跟Threads 懂不懂
不要看截圖 懂不懂
這個很普通的詐騙不要被騙了 懂嗎
你會發現到哲哲真的很奇怪
我跟你講 我要是聳動一點
講這些什麼有漲停 又漲停
你知道 憑我的粉絲人數
我收不完的錢
我沒有在乎啦 好不好
懂不懂 OK嗎
所以人在做天在看
等一下 我看一下直播人數
所以今天要講的東西
台灣股市接下來會比較多賣壓
就是很容易開高走低
我這樣講 為什麼開高走低
因為會開高一定是這樣子
再講一次
我剛才直接預告
我再講一個預告
因為我剛才講的不夠直接
人家漲4% 台灣漲2%
台灣股市接下來很容易開高走低
開高走低不代表一定收跌
像今天也算開高走低
或者開到中間漲高 尾盤殺下去
因為台灣股市已經接近新高
其他家的股市都沒有接近新高
就這麼簡單 好不好
韓國股市離新高也很遠
記住這句話 所以開高走低
你喜歡做當沖 隔日沖的
當然我不建議
只是說你要走得快
這樣懂不懂 懂嗎
Understand
來 看一下大家的留言
川湖 不要
0050被陳幸妤帶紅
你這樣講我很難過
我講了20年了
應該被我帶紅的吧 來
請問老師 輝達財報那麼好
微星都不動
微星已經算強的
微星的缺點就是
這種老AI或是老電子股
比較那個 好不好
已經放空Meta
我很討厭臉書
我覺得臉書沒道德 來
就是幾乎都亂封鎖人家
00960跌爛了
果真航運相關的股票
好啦 我跟你講主動ETF
記得一件事
主動ETF 你看這一次
我是不是叫你買什麼
00981A
我說你看喔
主動統一台股增長
到現在差不多20% 不止喔
23.2到29.5
29.5喔 是不是
除以23.2對不對 對
27%啦
我要是1億放到現在是賺2700萬
所以我不當分析師
我真的可能會買它喔
可是我買它
主動型ETF
第一個我不買它是因為
我買股票我覺得可以賺更多啊 是
可是我又不能買股票
所以我只能買台灣50
第二個 我給你推薦主動型ETF
我怕你不會用
會用是搶反彈的時候搶它
可是中長期呢
還是台灣50
第二個 你真的要買主動型ETF
你不要跟我講一堆有的沒有
真的像之前00878
不是也說很好嗎
最後老牌0056還是贏它
我們福利社也跟你講
它家底比較厚
比較多股利可以發
那個我都講過
我真的預測很強
我還是要再跟你講一次
你們以後會發現到
不敢說像國外9成 甚至9成5
我覺得台灣至少
到時候主動型ETF 至少80%
就5檔裡面有4檔
績效會輸台灣50
OK 這個我滿有信心的 是
那你何必呢 你選主動型ETF
還在選哪一檔贏台灣50
你不如就買台灣50
你喜歡積極一點呢
買主動型ETF
不要 那你就買被動元件嘛
買低檔的華新科 華邦電嘛
是不是
刺激一點
穩的就選台灣50
部份資金來跟我做股票也可以啊
懂不懂 Understand
知道嗎 知不知道
來啦 所以27%你知道
這個到創新高
開始可以換了
快要創新高可以換了
我是不是很準
我說準備要創新高了
那31 32
就準備要換台灣50了
好不好 31 32準備換台灣50了
中長期還是台灣50比較好
第三個我要跟你講
你們真的要買主動型ETF
記得一件事
買第一檔 統一就買第一檔
主動統一 是
就買主動統一台股增長
我說如果要的話
就每一檔的 各家的每一檔ETF
券商 基金 公司
這一家公司第一檔ETF就好
第二檔不要買
我不是瞧不起他們
而是如果我是老闆的話
我第一檔已經是一炮而紅
我不會第一檔選比較普通的
我說的沒錯吧
我一定第一檔選最強的
最強的那個基金經理人
知道嗎 我講得有沒有道理 有
已經跟你講了
這些東西講難聽點
跟我收會員有什麼關係
我人很好啦
還有力嗎
30元以上我就覺得可以換了
你們自己換
我這個不收會員的
都把我的秘密講出來了
沒關係 我會員的股票更飆
群聯換南亞科
其實老實跟你講
我感覺南亞科可能有機會更飆
但是我就喜歡不追
我跟你講
我現在想到兩全其美的方法
華邦電可不可以買
華邦電離高點還是很遠 是不是
也是啊 華邦電OK是不是
華邦電 你看2408南亞科
是要漲到天邊 漲到1000塊
不是不可能
感覺籌碼都被主力大戶
被中實戶 不要用主力兩個字形容人家
中實戶 大戶給吸走了
接下來要拉
今天看起來創新高
他厲害 真的厲害
8299群聯真的是
一個漲25塊 一個漲30塊
但是股價差很多 是
你可以買2344
我跟你講 我覺得啦
我覺得假設
我覺得你可以考慮
你記得我這句話
5檔裡面對不對 5檔所宗
我這樣講好像我是國民黨
我只是想梗而已
不論國民黨 民進黨 民眾黨
記得一件事
哲哲不喜歡講政治
不要分你我 我愛你們 OK
要分的話記得
不要去日本給人家潑油 有點丟臉
真的啦
分台灣人 扯遠了
來 我要講什麼東西
5檔所宗 還是要講這個梗
你看分析師
都要在乎你們的感受
5檔所宗 5檔裡面我覺得
你可以考慮到最多2檔記憶體
記憶體可以1到2檔好不好
你覺得太多了 就30%記憶體 是
或3檔裡面有1檔
或者說2檔然後各差不多15% 各17%
差不多3分之1的記憶體
這個可以的 不要超過40%
因為3 40%已經很多了
被動元件逢低也可以買
這麼便宜 你們拜託
你們真的會後悔
AI很恐怖
你們到底知不知道這個題材
我覺得我有時候瞧不起一些
外資分析師
他們都看財報 那沒有
來 再跟我講一次
那些財報沒有用 沒有
為什麼沒有用
看數字 盤後股價漲5%
你看營收增加這麼快 有沒有看到
很漂亮對不對 是
2027年度營收估增70%
不是需求上限
供給如果跟得上
記憶體如果跟得上的話
成長還可能更高
這是公司講的
分析師原預期只有44% 我70%
你們每一個人
你們華爾街每一個人
都罵那些AI老闆是白癡
照樣擴增給你看 為什麼
誰是白癡
你們根本都不用手機
我每天都用
不論是改歌詞也好 或做什麼
其實他很好用
我不能教太多
Lily對不對
一開始你覺得他很難用
後來也是覺得很好用對不對
會用就會很好用
就是我講的 一開始你可能覺得
投資長 這個怎麼這樣講
一直念說我這個要用AI
你不覺得真的越用
你會離不開他 是 真的
你會什麼事都問他
重點是你要會用
你們不會用啊
你們不會用至少看我的節目
你知道多恐怖
他已經超越你們的人了
而且我今天看到一個東西 你知道嗎
其實我跟你講
為什麼現在玉晶光這些股價也漲了
機器人 我要收回我的言論
機器人成長速度也比想像中快 是
有人說那只是模型
你知道中國大陸已經在比賽什麼
比賽百米賽跑就算了
還比賽機器人格鬥
這就算了
還比賽機器人500米障礙這種的
還可以匍匐前進 是
還有那個障礙賽
前面一面牆 然後把他爬起來
那個腳還可以縮起來
好像人 你知道好恐怖
我跟你講那個真的
你們真的很幸福
就像我講的
這十年趕快把三高養好
以後很多癌症會治好
不論是醫學方面 機器人方面
不論是生活運用方面
唯一最恐怖的是很多人會失業
沒關係 在你失業的時候
你有失業補貼救濟金
失業補貼的救濟金 買股票啊 是
你們快要氣死 匪夷所思
廢話 因為你們那些分析師
都沒在用AI嘛
你們自己說用多少時間 用多少問題
我不能再跟你講
太多我用AI的秘密
不然很多人會學走
不然我想舉很多例子 你知道嗎
會用AI的人
一個人可以抵100個
我越來越覺得我會用AI以後
我真的越來越厲害
我是跟你講真的
做什麼事
做什麼公司的策略 公司的營運
我真的覺得如虎添翼 真的
來 只是不能再講下去了
2027年營收估增
我只告訴你那些人
你覺得哲哲很聰明
你覺得不會有哲哲一樣聰明
或比哲哲更聰明的人嗎
那些AI 做AI的老闆
都看到這個趨勢了
他們知道就是趨勢
很多人不看好AI 用了AI以後
你告訴我為什麼
巴菲特現在投資Google
他幾乎不投資AI股 他要退休
他那種個性的人不會真的退休啦
你懂嗎
他一定做到死最後一刻 為什麼
為什麼他打臉自己
看到AI以後發現
全世界真的有機器人比他聰明
真正聰明的人是虛懷若谷
我很謙虛
像谷一樣 像深淵一樣
我知道自己不足的地方
我告訴你AI真的很恐怖
你們自己不用而已 你知道
我舉一堆例子
都可以模擬人 然後對話了
你們要去想一件事
那些人看到會看到商機
他會投資它
成長太誇張了
真正機器人成長
他不是線性 再講一次
基本上不是線性的
線性是這樣子 我長 這樣長
不是 他是這樣
當他成熟的時候他是這樣長
不會逆時
有啦 青春可能會逆時
這樣長 幾乎90度
他自己還會生成AI
自己再生成AI
你不要覺得不可能
你懂嗎 這個我跟大家講
好不好 來
補教業也是一樣
以後會比較不值錢
今天我進陽明是正確還是笨的
我不會買陽明 我就說了 好不好
所以這些聰明的人
就是會怎麼樣
知道說要投資AI
所以我跟你講
每次都說泡沫 泡沫
很快就生出那些獲利模式了
我認為在半年內你就會
原來AI也可以用這個賺錢
原來也有AI公司用這個賺錢
AI真的可以用機器人
AI機器人還要一段時間
但是已經很快了
AI自駕車也很快了
AI看到你很多模式
AI可以改進公司的工作流程
有那種新興的AI
奧特曼講的跟我想的一模一樣
我有講了 AI進步很快
但是應用上還很慢
因為大家有習慣
就是因為你有這個落差
公司要有習慣
所以我可以用AI去
我幫你們改善你們公司流程
我新興的AI公司可以做這些東西 是
我新興的AI公司可以做這些東西
我幫你改善公司的軟體
幫你改善公司的作業流程
你懂嗎 比如說我們要參加會員對不對
我們以前會填表單 對
對不對 填完表單以後
我再跟你講要寫幾個月
參加3個月 參加6個月
還是參加1年
我是不是可以做一個流程
我只要拍照就好了
或者我線上打字就好
打完字以後
我就馬上一鍵按下去Enter
就告訴我這個會員參加3個月
這個會員參加1年
那參加什麼老師 什麼等級會員
全部都把它做好了
以前是人工要處理
或者是由系統處理
以後基本上都不用了
一個鍵按下去 為什麼
因為現在寫程式很簡單
因為以前可能要打字
有些人不會打字
我用拍照可不可以
可以啊 因為拍照現在解析程度很OK
十幾年前你要停車的時候
是不是都沒有什麼eTag
因為看不出來你那個牌照
看不出來你的車牌號碼
現在都沒問題了
臉部辨識都沒問題了 是
很恐怖你知不知道 是不是
所以我要講
這些辨識方面
都可以改善你的流程
每家公司都可以改善流程
你要記得有這件事情
那AI 那是你們看不懂未來就覺得
所以我跟你講
10萬點我覺得 我還小小的說
10萬點我是保守
為什麼 因為沒有達到會很丟臉
你要我猜12萬點 13萬點我都可以
如果你是我的朋友
我都想跟你賭了
只是不想建立不好的形象 來
今天怎麼沒有念帆宣會員讚訊
我看一下
所以我沒有要去收錢嘛
來 我們念一下
來 精材漲停 精材快漲停
恭喜3374精材
股價大漲超過7%
準備再創近期新高
我們買進到現在
最高已經大賺70%
我持續看好他 手上持股獲利續抱
我跟你講精材
裡面看起來有超大戶在裡面
都在玩我們
那你怎麼樣讓大戶不要玩
就不要隨波逐流嘛
你管他 你就抱久一點嘛 是不是
他洗不掉你的時候
他就會拉起來了好不好
萬潤啦 6189萬潤是不是
以前100元的時候被人家罵死
現在1430元
真的啊 前幾年而已
前幾年而已啦 你們不要不相信啦
2022年53塊不到 扯不扯
2022年53塊不到 是
你看啊去年而已 去年不到
去年200塊而已
201扯不扯
現在1400
一堆股票 我買的很多股票
我跟你講 為什麼有時候會員
大部分很多會員
參加我的是一直續約
有些會員討厭我以後
過幾個月 過幾年還參加我的會員
哲哲 我那時候罵你萬潤 是不是
哲哲我時候那時候罵你欣興
搞得我像沸沸揚揚一樣 是不是
怎麼會這樣子
8 90塊罵你
結果呢 現在1180元了
去年這個時候
去年這個時候才6 70而已怎麼辦
去年這個時候不到100元啊
現在1180元
一開始覺得我的股票不怎麼樣
我的股票怎麼那麼慢
後來發現不是我的股票慢
是你太急了
一年漲10倍很誇張啊
那這種股票你都等不下去能怎麼辦
那你就不要看我的節目了 知道嗎
我是為大家好 OK嗎 來啦
真的會10萬點的 我沒騙你
你們要懂AI的恐怖
我只是覺得我運氣也不錯
但是我也是掌握潮流
很多人說哲哲你很紅
你有沒有想過為什麼我很紅
因為豬站在風口上也會怎麼樣
會飛 也會飛
我就是知道 我就是那一個豬
知道哪邊有風口 懂不懂
投資長別這樣說
別自己說出來
不會啊 我覺得不會怎麼樣
我就是那個豬
我就知道哪邊有風
我就往那邊吹
就這樣子 順勢而為而已啦
很多人說我很厲害
我有時候跟你開玩笑說
我畫K線給你看
應該說我只是知道K線怎麼走而已
這樣好不好 OK
有些講話比較誇張啦
比較綜藝效果
恭喜華新科股價尾盤急拉
收盤漲超過5%
不知不覺
我怎麼有秀出華新科的簡訊
什麼時候買的
我這麼多會員這能造假嗎
股價尾盤急拉
收盤超過5%
手上持股獲利續抱
我講了至少幾十遍了
沒有寫簡訊的
沒有寫那個等級的
就是普通會員的簡訊
這個都很清楚
收漲超過5%
手上持股獲利續抱
來 恭喜3374精材
還有 對
所以這些東西
對了 我要進一下廣告
我突然又想到梗
我的腦袋很急很快
你知道我很急很快嗎
我要休息一下
因為我最近還在提告人家 是
因為之前有個分析師
說你沒有寫這個簡訊就是假的
他的邏輯真的很奇怪
莫名其妙 對啊
莫名其妙 我聽到就很生氣
如果是假的早就怎麼樣
早就一堆人怎麼樣
會員會抱怨
早就抱怨了 不需要他來爆料 是不是
所以我這個點要寫進去
先休息一下
沒有啦 我還是休息一下
跟你講更多飆股
現在幾分鐘 還是不用休息了
46不用休息了
等一下那個導播幫我記得這一段
好不好 扯遠了
因為我有點過動兒
所以你看我講話跳很快 跳來跳去
一件事情可以
一分鐘大概可以
有時候一分鐘想的快
可以想十幾件都不誇張
跳來跳去
哲哲我兒子大四
他說你看股票很準 謝謝啦 來啦
聯電這種渣男股快丟了吧
我看是不是渣男
有人這樣講聯電 那麼激動
不是啦 它就是很慢的股票啦
不會太差啦
聯電最近是要擴產啦
資本支出太多大家怕啦 好不好
哲哲有時候自言自語
你聽不懂沒關係
聯電要發債沒錯
南亞科大戶 好不好
會10萬點的話要壓正2嗎
我講過幾百萬遍了
會10萬點
那有沒有可能哪一天股價腰斬誰知道
沒錯
是不是 或打世界大戰誰知道
你腰斬 你受得了嗎 是不是
你沒借錢
但是正2就是一種期貨啊
它比較能接受 到現在沒出事
只是因為它槓桿很低啦
就是2倍槓桿而已啊 你懂不懂
怎麼樣都比融資好
融資很多都2.5倍了嘛 對不對
而且融資會直接要你斷頭 是不是
這個跟你講
只是我給你教那麼多幹嘛
100個裡面有一個聽不懂
不是害了他
所以我買台灣50 就這樣子
其他你自己要抓低點你自己抓
好不好 來
我就說我寧願少賺
我也不要讓你多賠
記得我的口頭禪 好不好
這是我的個性
而且正2他們發行的時候
正2發行 元大自己講
正2不適合長期
他自己說的 是
公開說明書有講 來
國巨明天站上買
環球晶1000元以下閉眼買
我真的覺得1000元以下
真的可以閉著眼睛買 真的啦
真的啦 到時候它會很缺 你相信我
他們擴產都很慢 你知道嗎
來 最後還有什麼股票
對 華新科明天應該也會噴出去
我跟你講 我真的
我再跟你講一件事
這一波頸線
來 這邊就是大概300多 320元
320元這邊對不對 對
這一波我覺得遲早都會上去
我不求前高這麼高
但是我覺得這邊突破這一波的高點
這一波反彈高點
我覺得顯而易見
因為前波實在太慘烈了
這樣懂不懂
我不敢說什麼1200
國巨也是一樣
這是700元對不對 對
這一波低點大概600多 快600多
我看一下600幾
668很快就會突破了
668 你看它現在才555
555有沒有看到 3個5
這才555 668
投資朋友這遲早會突破的
記得我的預告好不好
我認為啦 我們是合格分析師 來
請問帆宣 帆宣看一下
今天大家很想要帆宣
說帆宣有沒有什麼
剛才有人說什麼帆宣有恭賀簡訊
剛才那個人把他封鎖
帆宣今天跌有什麼恭賀簡訊
真的很無聊
帆宣也沒什麼
帆宣就是比較難動 是不是
真的不行 我跟你講
如果很難動的股票我是有考慮
比如說帆宣或鴻海
成本附近我是有考慮
因為每個人成本不同
是考慮要換
但是這是我的會員權益
那個有些人愛抱怨的免費仔就沒辦法
你是我的粉絲
但是我不會抱怨你
不能不繳錢又抱怨
這就不行了 好不好 OK嗎
來 所以帆宣那個我覺得
等一段時間
就像你剛才說微星
你們不要急好不好
大盤才剛驚魂未定
到現在已經開始收驚了 是
行情總在半信半疑中成長
你說微星有沒有很差
也沒到差
你看他 你自己認真看
上升趨勢線有降嗎
感覺好像也沒有
上升趨勢線有破嗎
好像也沒有 不是嗎 沒有啊
上升趨勢線沒有 你自己看一下
嚴格來說上升趨勢線沒有破 對
那你在怕什麼 再拉起來
只是它的缺點是
它沒有漲多少
說錯了 它的缺點是它沒有跌多少
所以反彈力道不夠大 是
所以我選低基期的股票 國巨
禾伸堂今天又拉起來
既生巨禾伸堂
有國巨幹嘛怕禾伸堂 好不好
好啦 導播一直跳來跳去 幾分了
52了喔 結束了
Byebye 不好意思 我愛你們
難怪導播跳來跳去
不論對或錯一切的一切我預告在前面
你看我燃燒生命
趕快來參加我的會員好不好
今天的股票太飆了
你不要到時候國巨
到時候突破那些前高
你再來找我
還有環球晶再來找我
歡迎來電洽詢0800668085
或者加我LINE私訊我
跟我說哲哲 我要賺大錢
我答應你 我竭盡所能來幫你賺大錢